so let's talk a little bit about
supplemental insurance now it is what
the words describe it as it is a
supplement to usually some other
existing insurance it's Insurance above
and beyond things that you might already
have so there's a lot of examples of
supplemental insurance but they usually
try to specif they usually try to cover
specific things that you might worry
about for example there might be
mortgage payoff life insurance one of
the main reasons why for example I have
life insurance is if something were to
happen to me I want my family to still
be able to live in our house and to be
able to pay off our mortgage and not
worry about where that income is coming
in so I've gotten enough life insurance
to do that but the insurance companies
know that sometimes people worry
specifically about that situation and so
people might get that very specific type
of life insurance mortgage payoff life
insurance which you could view as a
supplement to traditional life insurance
now if you've got enough life insurance
you should be able to pay your mortgage
and then hopefully do other things that
your family needs to support them but
this might be a supplement that you look
at but whenever you you look at any form
of insurance realize that the insurance
company has done the statistics and
they're going to make money off of it
now that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
do it oftentimes it will protect you in
a lot of ways so it is worth doing it
but you should think about whether you
need to do it or whether it's already
covered by another insurance you have
another example is car insurance you
might have comprehensive car insurance
already where if the car not only gets
in an accident but if it's if it's
stolen if a tree falls on it the
insurance company will pay you the cash
value of the car and so if you wanted
you could go and get another used car
just like that now some people if you're
not paying off your debt fast enough on
your car loan the cash value of your car
might be less than the amount that you
owe back on your car now that's in
general not a good situation if you're
paying back your car loan slower than
your car is actually losing value not a
good great situation to be in but a lot
of folks wouldn't want to get money from
an insurance company for say a car got
totaled and it still can't even pay back
the total loan available in the car so
they have things like Auto auto loan
payoff car insurance which you could use
a supplement to traditional insurance
but once again it's not a great
situation to be in and in theory even if
the insurance company is paying you the
cash value you can go and get an
equivalent used car and even though you
owe more money than that you're kind of
in the same situation you were before
the accident or whatever the scenario
you were in but the general principle
supplemental is above and beyond maybe
you have insurance dental insurance or
life insurance or some other type
insurance from your employer and you're
just think hey I would like more
Insurance they're not giving me enough
well that could be a good reason to get
supplemental insurance as well